Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The issue before you is a simple one. As a country, we face grave problems at home and abroad. Do you want a strong government, which has clear authority for the future, to take the decisions which will be needed? Do you want Parliament and the elected government to continue to fight
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。摆在你们面前的问题很简单。作为一个国家，我们在国内和国际上都面临着严峻的问题。你们是否希望有一个拥有明确未来决策权的强有力的政府，来做出必要的决定？你们是否希望议会和民选政府继续努力
strenuously against inflation? Or do you want them to abandon the struggle against rising prices under pressure from one particularly powerful group of workers? This time, the strife has got to stop. Only you can stop it. It's time for you to speak with your vote. It's time for your voice to be heard. The voice of the moderate and reasonable people of Britain. The voice of the majority. It's time for you to say to the extremists, the militants, and the plain and simply misguided, we've had enough. There's a lot to be done. For heaven's sake, let's get on with it. So that, Dominic, was Edward Heath. Uncanny someone. Who was, well, he ended up living in Salisbury, so a man I've always identified with.
与通货膨胀进行坚决的斗争？还是希望他们在某个特别强大的工人团体的压力下，放弃对抗物价上涨的斗争？这一次，纷争必须停止。只有你们能阻止它。是时候用你们的选票来表达了。是时候让你们的声音被听到了。这是英国温和而理性的人民的声音。这是大多数人的声音。是时候对那些极端分子、激进分子以及那些单纯被误导的人说：我们受够了。有很多事情要做。看在上帝的份上，让我们开始行动吧。那么，多米尼克，刚才那是爱德华·希思。一个不可思议的人。他最终住在索尔兹伯里，所以我一直很有认同感。
And he, of course, was Prime Minister between 1970 and 1974. And there he was on the 7th of February 1974, addressing the nation and basically saying, everything's gone tits up. It's a nightmare. We're going to have to have an election. That's right. Because today's theme is 1974. We're looking at British politics in 1974, the period which you have described as being the worst year in British political history. Right. Well, that was almost exactly 50 years ago, Tom. And Ted Heath was asking the British people famously, who governs the elected government or the trade unions or the National Union of Mine Workers? And famously, the answer from the public was, not you. So yes, I think it probably, there is a very good argument that 1974, the year I was born, was the worst year in modern British political history. So post-war, obviously. Certainly post-war. So it sees one minor strike,
当然，他在1970年到1974年间担任首相。1974年2月7日，他向全国发表讲话，基本上是在说，一切都搞砸了。这简直是一场噩梦。我们必须进行选举。没错。因为今天的主题是1974年。我们正在回顾1974年的英国政治，这段时期被你描述为英国政治史上最糟糕的一年。没错。汤姆，那几乎正好是50年前的事了。泰德·希思当时著名地问英国人民：谁在治理国家？是民选政府，还是工会，或者是全国矿工工会？而公众著名的回答是：不是你。所以是的，我认为有一个很好的论点，即我出生的那一年——1974年，是现代英国政治史上最糟糕的一年。当然是战后。肯定是战后。所以它见证了一次矿工罢工，
the second in two years. It sees two elections. It sees a three-day week. It sees an interminable series of bombings and terrorist attacks, both in Northern Ireland and in Britain, in London particularly. It sees countless predictions of coups and the breakdown of law and order, so on and so forth. England lose the ashes. England lose the ashes. England don't qualify for the 1974 World Cup. It's a year that I think has become emblematic of the global crisis of the 1970s, but specifically in Britain, it's the year that's become emblematic of the collapse of the sort of social democratic post-war consensus.
这是两年内的第二次。它见证了两次选举。它见证了每周三天工作制。它见证了北爱尔兰和英国（尤其是伦敦）发生的一系列没完没了的爆炸和恐怖袭击。它见证了无数关于政变和法律秩序崩溃的预言，等等。英格兰输掉了骨灰瓮板球赛。英格兰输掉了骨灰瓮板球赛。英格兰没能获得1974年世界杯的参赛资格。我认为这一年已经成为20世纪70年代全球危机的象征，但具体到英国，它是社会民主主义战后共识崩溃的象征。
And it's the key moment, 1973-74, in the coming of Thatcherism, which will happen at the end of the decade. And so for listeners who are not British, who may not be particularly interested in the nuance of British politics, I mean, the reason this is such a fascinating episode is that, I mean, Britain is a very stable democracy, but this is the year where it really seems to be wobbling. And so we should say straight up that this is a subject of two of your books, State of Emergency, which goes up to the end of the Heath government, and then Seasons in the Sun, which begins with the Wilson government, which succeeds Heath's government and
这是1973-74年的关键时刻，预示着撒切尔主义的到来，而撒切尔主义将在十年末发生。对于那些不是英国人、可能对英国政治细微差别不太感兴趣的听众来说，这一集之所以如此引人入胜，是因为英国是一个非常稳定的民主国家，但这一年它似乎真的摇摇欲坠。所以我们应该直截了当地说，这是你两本书的主题，《紧急状态》（State of Emergency）讲述到希思政府结束，然后是《阳光下的季节》（Seasons in the Sun），从接替希思政府的威尔逊政府开始，
goes up to 1979. They are brilliant books. Oh, Tom, so kind. You know, fantastic analysis of British politics, but also incredibly funny. So for listeners, you know, outside Britain thinking, oh, do I really want to listen to this? I would urge you to stick with it, both because it is fascinating as an analysis of how a very stable democracy can go through, you know, horrors and yet ultimately emerge from it. And simultaneously, it's very funny. I mean, it's a kind of, it's a dark comedy comedy it is because it's set against the backdrop of the 70s so the 70s is not just kind of inflation and oil crises and things but it's also a very gaudy moment in kind of popular culture so it's 1974 the abba won the eurovision song contest tom with uh with waterloo it's the year
一直写到1979年。它们是杰出的著作。哦，汤姆，你太客气了。你知道，对英国政治的精彩分析，而且非常有趣。所以对于英国以外的听众，如果觉得“我真的想听这个吗？”，我强烈建议你们坚持听下去，因为它不仅是对一个非常稳定的民主国家如何经历恐怖却最终走出困境的迷人分析，同时它也非常有趣。我的意思是，这是一种黑色喜剧，因为它以70年代为背景，所以70年代不仅有通货膨胀和石油危机，也是流行文化中非常浮夸的时刻，比如1974年，ABBA乐队赢得了欧洲歌唱大赛，汤姆，凭借《滑铁卢》，那是
of the grumble in the jungle of the godfather part two of course famously tom it's the year that wolverhampton wanderers won the league cup at wembley against manchester city so very important yes i thought you'd come to that now just to give people especially either our younger listeners or people who are outside britain a bit of context we should just set the scene by saying what had happened to britain since the war so there are two main things so one is that in the sort of 20 to 30 years since the end of the Second World War, Britain has retreated almost completely from empire. Its status in the world is vastly diminished. An extraordinary transformation, actually, with remarkably few domestic repercussions, I would say.
“丛林中的隆隆声”（拳王阿里与福尔曼的世纪之战）、《教父2》的一年，当然，汤姆，众所周知，那是伍尔弗汉普顿流浪者队在温布利击败曼城队赢得联赛杯的一年，所以非常重要。是的，我想你会提到这个。现在，为了给人们，特别是我们年轻的听众或英国以外的听众提供一点背景，我们应该先说明一下战后英国发生了什么。主要有两件事：第一，在二战结束后的20到30年里，英国几乎完全从帝国撤退了。它在世界上的地位大大降低。实际上，这是一场非凡的转变，而且我可以说，在国内几乎没有什么反响。
I mean, I think it's hard to think of any country in history that has suffered quite such an implosion of its global status in so short a time. With so few consequences, Tom. Never an election issue, never a massive deal, I would say, in domestic politics. It's not entirely voluntary, but it's as though people just aren't talking about it. So there's that, there's the retreat from empire. And I think one of the key things in the 70s Britain is that people feel a sense of diminished prestige. Number two is, for all the sort of excitement of the 60s and whatnot, Britain is going through a period of deep economic and very traumatic economic transformation. So the first
我的意思是，很难想到历史上有什么国家在如此短的时间内经历了如此巨大的全球地位崩溃。汤姆，而且后果如此之少。我可以说，这从来不是选举议题，也从来不是国内政治中的大事。这并不完全是自愿的，但人们似乎就是不谈论它。所以这就是撤退，从帝国撤退。我认为70年代英国的一个关键点是，人们感到一种声望的下降。第二点是，尽管60年代有各种兴奋，但英国正在经历一段深刻且非常痛苦的经济转型。所以第一个
industrial nation is now becoming the first to de-industrialize. People losing their jobs, unemployment is beginning to go up, inflation is becoming a bigger and bigger problem. That was evident more than 10 years before. And the public had elected a new government led by Labour's Harold Wilson to try and deal with it in 1964. The white heat of technology, he famously said. And he had promised to modernize Britain, to create a new Britain in the white heat of the technological revolution. And by and large, he had failed.
工业化国家现在正成为第一个去工业化的国家。人们失去工作，失业率开始上升，通货膨胀成为越来越大的问题。这在10多年前就已经很明显了。公众在1964年选举了一个由工党哈罗德·威尔逊领导的新政府来试图解决这个问题。他曾著名地说道：“技术的白热”。他承诺要实现英国的现代化，在技术革命的白热中创造一个新英国。但总的来说，他失败了。
So the electorate had kicked him out in 1970. He'd had to devalue the pound. There'd been constant problems with strikes, with international pressure on the British currency, lack of confidence in the British economy and so on. And so in 1970, the electorate had chosen another modernizer, the man you were so brilliantly impersonating at the beginning of the programme. Thank you, Dominic. Thank you. Which is Edward Heath.
所以选民在1970年把他赶下台了。他不得不让英镑贬值。一直存在罢工问题，国际社会对英国货币施加压力，对英国经济缺乏信心等等。因此在1970年，选民选择了另一位现代化者，就是你在节目开头精彩模仿的那个人。谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢。那就是爱德华·希思。
And the story of this episode and the next episode, a lot of it is what you might call the tragedy of Edward Heath. The rudest man ever to be Prime Minister, you might say. Yeah. So perhaps we should talk a little about Heath because he's a new kind of Tory. He was born in 1916. He's from Kent and he's actually the kind of of tory he was born in 1916 he's from kent and he's actually the son of a very skilled kind of carpenter stroke builder and his mother was a lady's maid wasn't she was a lady's maid yeah so that's i mean kind of interesting because he
这一集和下一集的故事，很大程度上可以被称为爱德华·希思的悲剧。你可能会说，他是史上最粗鲁的首相。是的。所以也许我们应该谈谈希思，因为他是一种新型的保守党人。他出生于1916年。他来自肯特郡，实际上他是那种……他出生于1916年，来自肯特郡，实际上他是一位非常有技术的木匠兼建筑工的儿子，他的母亲是女仆，不是吗？她是女仆，是的。所以这很有趣，因为他
becomes the leader of the tories which traditionally have been the party of the kind of landed yes aristocracy and everything and the lady's maid was always the ambivalent servant in downtown kind of midway between the servants hall and upstairs. And there's something about that in Heath, is there? Do you think? Oh, definitely. Definitely. These things really matter. And it definitely matters with Heath. So Heath's little boy had been your absolute classic spoiled prodigy. So all the accounts of him growing up in Broadstairs in Kent are that he's perfect. He's never naughty. He always does the right thing. He's clever and everything at home is geared around him. So he has a special chair in which he can do his homework. He doesn't have to help with the washing up. He's bought a
成为了保守党的领袖，而保守党传统上是那种拥有土地的贵族政党。女仆在《唐顿庄园》里总是那种矛盾的仆人，介于仆人厅和楼上之间。希思身上有这种特质吗？你觉得呢？哦，绝对有。绝对有。这些事情真的很重要。对于希思来说，这绝对很重要。希思小时候是个典型的被宠坏的神童。关于他在肯特郡布罗德斯泰斯长大的所有描述都是他很完美。他从不淘气。他总是做正确的事。他很聪明，家里的一切都围绕着他转。他有一把专门的椅子用来做作业。他不需要帮忙洗碗。他被买了一架
piano because he's very good at the piano. Their family dog is named after him. He's given his initials, ERG. AndR-G, Erg. And at school, you know, everyone would say of Heath, he's like the sort of the incarnation of the school spirit, you know, but in a really kind of off-putting way. So he's the sort of boy who's a prefect at school when everybody says, you know, if he sees another boy breaking the school rules, he thinks that's disloyal to the school.
钢琴，因为他钢琴弹得很好。他们家的狗是以他的名字命名的。他被赋予了他的首字母缩写，ERG。ERG，Erg。在学校里，你知道，每个人都会说希思，他就像是学校精神的化身，但以一种非常令人反感的方式。所以他是那种在学校当级长的人，当每个人都说，如果他看到另一个男孩违反校规，他会认为那是对学校的不忠。
And Dominic, does he end up going to Oxford? And if he does, which college does he go to? He does. And he went to Balliol College, Oxford. Tom, like all the best people. And a famous story about him at Balliol College is that he was friends with a future Labour politician, Dennis Healey. And one day they were walking through the Balliol Quad and Dennis Healey said to him that a mutual friend who was also in the Labour Party, like Dennis Healey, or Dennis Healey
多米尼克，他最后去牛津了吗？如果是的话，他去了哪个学院？他去了。他去了牛津大学贝利奥尔学院。汤姆，像所有最优秀的人一样。关于他在贝利奥尔学院的一个著名故事是，他和未来的工党政治家丹尼斯·希利是朋友。有一天，他们走过贝利奥尔方庭，丹尼斯·希利对他说，一个也是工党的朋友，像丹尼斯·希利一样，或者说丹尼斯·希利
was actually a communist in those days. He said a mutual friend, he's going off to a pub for the weekend. He's going to stay there with his girlfriend. They're going to pretend to be a married couple. And Ted Heath apparently was so shocked. And he said, my goodness, he said, nobody in the Conservative Party would ever behave like that. And he meant it.
当时实际上是个共产主义者。他说，一个共同的朋友要去酒吧过周末。他要和女朋友待在那里。他们要假装成一对已婚夫妇。泰德·希思显然非常震惊。他说：“天哪，保守党里没有人会做出那种事。”他是认真的。
He absolutely meant it. Because he famously never went to bed with anyone. Never married. Not a man for the ladies. He had an extraordinary time as a young man. He went to Germany in the 1930s on a kind of tour. He met Goering, Goebbels and Himmler. Because he was at the Nuremberg Rally, wasn't he?
他绝对是认真的。因为众所周知，他从不和任何人上床。从未结婚。不是那种喜欢女人的男人。他年轻时有一段非凡的经历。他在20世纪30年代去德国进行了一次旅行。他见到了戈林、戈培尔和希姆莱。因为他在纽伦堡集会上，不是吗？
He was at the Nuremberg Rallys, taken by a sort of Oxford friend. And he shook hands, apparently, with Himmler. And he said Himmler had a very poor handshake, which does not surprise me. No. Limp and moist, I imagine. Yes. Then he went on holiday to the Spanish Civil War. He shook hands apparently with Himmler and he said that Himmler had a very poor handshake, which does not surprise me. No. Limp and moist, I imagine. Yes. Then he went on holiday to the Spanish Civil War and he was machine gunned by a nationalist plane.
他在纽伦堡集会上，是被一个牛津朋友带去的。显然，他和希姆莱握了手。他说希姆莱的握手非常糟糕，这并不让我感到惊讶。不。我想是软绵绵、湿漉漉的。是的。然后他去西班牙内战度假……显然他和希姆莱握了手，他说希姆莱的握手非常糟糕，这并不让我感到惊讶。不。我想是软绵绵、湿漉漉的。是的。然后他去西班牙内战度假，结果被一架民族主义者的飞机用机枪扫射。
The car he was in was machine gunned. And then he served in the Second World War time and commanded, was it in the artillery, I think, or the engineers or something like that, fighting their way into Germany. Because that is part of the backdrop of this, isn't it? And it's the same with the Falklands War, which we talked about earlier, that all the characters in this drama, they kind of have thick glasses or hunched shoulders and slightly shabby suits. Dandruff.
他坐的车被机枪扫射了。然后他在二战期间服役，指挥了——我想是在炮兵部队，或者是工程兵部队之类的，一路打进德国。因为这也是背景的一部分，不是吗？这和我们之前谈到的福克兰群岛战争一样，这部剧里的所有角色，他们都有厚厚的眼镜，或者驼背，穿着稍微有点破旧的西装。头皮屑。
But they'd all been insanely brave in the war. That's right. So they all have those kind of memories. Exactly. To kind of buoy them. And for Heath, this memory of seeing the Nazis, of the Spanish Civil War, of fighting in the Second World War, I mean, this informs what becomes the great crusade of his career, isn't it? Which is to get Britain into the common market as
但他们在战争中都极其勇敢。没错。所以他们都有那种记忆。正是如此。用来支撑他们。对于希思来说，这种看到纳粹、经历西班牙内战、在二战中战斗的记忆，这构成了他职业生涯伟大十字军东征的基础，不是吗？那就是让英国加入共同市场，
it was. Yes. He's a passionate Europhile. He went back to Nuremberg to see the trials at the end of the war. And he sits there in the courtroom and he says in his memoirs, as I watched these scenes, I thought to myself, never again. You know, the way to deal with this is to have European brotherhood and solidarity and absolutely all of this kind of thing. And as you say, the funny thing is that all the characters we'll be talking about, so many of them, they appear to be so ineffectual and just sort of world weary and stuff.
当时是这样。是的。他是一个热情的亲欧派。他在战争结束时回到纽伦堡观看审判。他坐在法庭里，在回忆录中写道，当我看到这些场景时，我对自己说，绝不再发生。你知道，处理这件事的方法是建立欧洲兄弟情谊和团结，绝对是所有这些东西。正如你所说，有趣的是，我们谈论的所有角色，他们中的许多人，看起来是如此无能，只是那种厌倦了世界等等。
They'd been storming beaches and machine gunning Panzer divisions. What kinds of things. They had. Maybe that's what happens. Yeah. If you storm a beach in your 20s, by the time you're 50,
他们曾经冲上海滩，用机枪扫射装甲师。各种各样的事情。他们确实做过。也许这就是发生的事情。是的。如果你在20多岁时冲上海滩，到你50岁时，
you look as though you're 80, you're knackered and you can't be bothered to do anything about anything. Yeah. Anyway. So, he is unbelievably rude.
你看起来就像80岁，你精疲力竭，对任何事情都提不起劲。是的。总之。所以，他极其粗鲁。
I think that's one other thing to remember about Ted Heath. Partly because he's so selfish. He's very poor at small talk. He's always been spoiled. He expects to be the centre of attention. And there are all these stories about him going to dinners and refusing to speak to people, especially women.
我认为关于泰德·希思，还有一点要记住。部分原因是他太自私了。他很不擅长闲聊。他一直被宠坏了。他希望成为关注的焦点。有许多关于他去参加晚宴却拒绝与人交谈的故事，尤其是女性。
Or there's a story that he's on a plane once when he's the Tory leader. And there's lots of turbulence that throws everybody to the floor, particularly this one woman journalist. And he says, bring brandy, bring brandy. And they bring brandy. And then he drinks it himself. So there's that behaviour.
或者有一个故事说，有一次他担任保守党领袖时在飞机上。有很多气流把每个人都扔到了地板上，特别是这位女记者。他说：“拿白兰地来，拿白兰地来。”他们拿来了白兰地。然后他自己喝了。所以有这种行为。
So he becomes Tory leader, doesn't he? And you're very funny about him. So you say he doesn't really like the Tory party. I suppose not. So you write about him, confronted by the extravagantly hatted housewives, blue-rinsed ladies, retired colonels, and nasal-voiced businessmen who stuffed envelopes and organised jumble sales on the party's behalf.
所以他成为了保守党领袖，不是吗？你对他非常幽默。你说他其实并不喜欢保守党。我想不是。所以你写道，面对那些戴着夸张帽子、头发染成蓝色、退休的上校以及鼻音浓重的商人们，他们代表党派装信封、组织义卖。
He often looked as though he had trodden in something. Yes. And he says of the MPs in his party, so Tory MPs, there are three sorts of people in this party. Shits, bloody shits, and fucking shits. Yes. So as you say, spectacularly rude but the reason they choose him goes to that voice that you've just done tom so heath has this strange strangulated
他经常看起来好像踩到了什么东西。是的。他谈到党内的议员时说，这个党里有三种人：混蛋、该死的混蛋和操蛋的混蛋。是的。所以正如你所说，极其粗鲁，但他们选择他的原因归结为你刚才模仿的那个声音，汤姆。所以希思有一种奇怪的、被扼住的
accent he adopted it when he was at oxford because previously he almost certainly spoke with a kind of kentish accent yeah so he's adopted what he sees as a patrician accent he's adopted the habits of the upper classes, copied them. So yachting. He plays the piano, all this kind of thing. Yeah, that sort of stuff. He's socially insecure, I think it's fair to say. And in 1965, after a succession of kind of very tweedy,
口音。他在牛津时采用了这种口音，因为在此之前，他几乎肯定带着一种肯特郡口音。是的，所以他采用了他认为的贵族口音，他采用了上层阶级的习惯，模仿了他们。比如游艇。他弹钢琴，所有这些东西。是的，那种东西。我认为公平地说，他在社交上缺乏安全感。1965年，在一连串那种非常粗呢的、
old Etonian Tory prime ministers had been kicked out, the Tories decided they needed a Harold Wilson of their own, a moderniser, an aspirational moderniser. The first Tory leader, they say they want with wall to wall carpeting. And Ted Heath is this man. And they believe he's the kind of British Kennedy. And there are these unbelievably ridiculous profiles. People say, you know, the classless professional politician.
老伊顿公学的保守党首相被赶下台后，保守党决定他们需要一个属于自己的哈罗德·威尔逊，一个现代化者，一个有抱负的现代化者。他们说他们想要的第一个保守党领袖要铺满地毯。泰德·希思就是这个人。他们相信他是英国的肯尼迪。还有那些令人难以置信的荒谬简介。人们说，你知道，无阶级的职业政治家。
My favorite one is from The Observer. It says, Ted Heath likes to gather people, young people around him. He summons them on the telephone. Like Kennedy, he's very intelligent. He ruthlessly uses intellectuals and experts to advise him, to feed him with facts. It's part of his technique, the computer mind at work. So he's a technocrat. He's a technocrat.
我最喜欢的一篇来自《观察家报》。它说，泰德·希思喜欢把人，年轻人聚集在他身边。他用电话召唤他们。像肯尼迪一样，他非常聪明。他无情地利用知识分子和专家来建议他，为他提供事实。这是他技术的一部分，计算机大脑在工作。所以他是个技术官僚。他是个技术官僚。
But I mean, all this stuff is obviously massively, you know, this sort of the ruthless modern. But this is how he sees himself, isn't it? As someone, you know, you have a problem, you solve it. Totally. He absolutely sees himself that way. He loves nothing more than a committee meeting of other technocrats, other kind of, you know, sensible, centrist people. Yeah. And they'll get together and they'll hammer out the best solution in the national interest.
但我的意思是，所有这些东西显然是非常，你知道，这种无情的现代。但这就是他看待自己的方式，不是吗？作为一个，你知道，你有一个问题，你解决它。完全正确。他绝对是那样看待自己的。他最喜欢的就是和其他技术官僚、其他那种，你知道，理性的、中间派的人开委员会会议。是的。他们会聚在一起，在国家利益的基础上敲定最好的解决方案。
And he, you know, you mentioned of computers there. He likes the idea of the economy as a kind of computer that, you know, you can tap a few things in and slightly shift it and then everything will go well. And this is basically the understanding of the economy that, I mean, Labour share it, right? Yeah, to some degree. I mean, the idea that you bring in a plan, the plan works, everything's brilliant. Yes. You've just got to get the right plan. Yes. He's a pure technocrat. He's basically a frustrated civil servant.
而且你提到了计算机。他喜欢把经济看作一种计算机，你知道，你可以输入一些东西，稍微调整一下，然后一切都会好起来。这基本上是工党也认同的经济理解，对吧？是的，在某种程度上。我的意思是，你引入一个计划，计划奏效，一切都很棒。是的。你只需要得到正确的计划。是的。他是一个纯粹的技术官僚。他基本上是一个受挫的公务员。
Although you say in your book that he's also a frustrated hotelier. Yes, yes. You know, which is, I mean, he'd be ruder than Basil Fawlty. He said to somebody that he wished he'd been a hotelier, and the mind absolutely boggles with that because he would have been so rude. But when he got into Downing Street in the 1970s, to general surprise, I would say, Labour's Harold Wilson, who was a much more intuitive politician,
尽管你在书中说他也是一个受挫的酒店经营者。是的，是的。你知道，我的意思是，他会比巴兹尔·福尔蒂更粗鲁。他曾对某人说，他希望自己能成为一名酒店经营者，这让人完全无法想象，因为他会非常粗鲁。但当他在1970年进入唐宁街时，总的来说，我认为工党的哈罗德·威尔逊，他是一个更直觉的政治家，
he was kicked out by the electorate in the summer of 1970. There'd been bad trade figures, they devalued the pound, the Wilson government was looking a bit shop-soiled. So in comes Heath, and he immediately redevelops Downing Street, number 10. So he modernized it. He put in all this sort of very garish kind of gold wallpaper and silver carpets. It's a very slightly Trumpian attitude to decor. And this is what he wants to do with Britain. He wants shiny new Britain with all sorts of changes. And he thinks very foolishly. He has an object lesson in doing too much too quickly.
他在1970年夏天被选民赶下台。贸易数据很糟糕，他们让英镑贬值，威尔逊政府看起来有点陈旧。所以希思上台了，他立即重新装修了唐宁街10号。所以他把它现代化了。他安装了所有那种非常俗气的金色壁纸和银色地毯。这是一种稍微有点特朗普式的装饰态度。这就是他想对英国做的事情。他想要一个闪亮的新英国，进行各种改变。他非常愚蠢地认为。他有一个做得太多太快的反面教材。
Well, he famously destroys the ancient county. He does. Doesn't he? Yes. He kind of reorgan lesson in doing too much too quickly. Well, he famously destroys the ancient counties. He does. Doesn't he? He kind of reorganises it. Yes, he does. Which I think is the one thing of which he can never really be forgiven. Well, it's very poor, Tom. It's very poor form from Ted Heath to have reorganised the counties in that way. I completely agree with you. He wants to get Britain into Europe, and indeed he does, in 1973. That's his big passion project. But also, I mean,
嗯，他著名地摧毁了古老的郡。他确实这样做了，不是吗？是的。他重新组织了它。是的，他确实这样做了。我认为这是他永远无法被原谅的一件事。嗯，这很糟糕，汤姆。泰德·希思以那种方式重新组织郡县是非常糟糕的做法。我完全同意你的看法。他想让英国加入欧洲，事实上他也做到了，在1973年。那是他最大的激情项目。但同时，我的意思是，
it's a very unpropitious time to be making lots of changes. There's rising inflation in the world economy generally because world commodity prices are going up. British industry has been performing pretty badly for years, so is coming under enormous pressure from foreign competition. And as a result, having said initially that he would be ruthless, he ends up handing out big bailouts to lots of British businesses. And there's another issue which is going to run all the way through this week's podcasts,
这是一个进行大量变革的非常不利的时机。世界经济普遍存在通货膨胀，因为世界大宗商品价格正在上涨。英国工业多年来表现相当糟糕，因此正受到外国竞争的巨大压力。结果，尽管他最初说他会无情，但他最终还是向许多英国企业发放了巨额救济金。还有一个问题将贯穿本周的播客，
which he's not responsible for, but which he doesn't necessarily handle terribly well. And this is the increasing violence in Northern Ireland. So this had begun in the mid-60s. This isn't a podcast about the troubles in Northern Ireland, but we'll just give you a tiny bit of background. This had begun in the mid-60s, intercommunal violence between the Catholic and Protestant communities of Northern Ireland. The British government sent in the army in 1969, actually to protect the Catholic community from Protestant rioters. But relations with the Catholics had broken down by the early 1970s.
他对此不负责任，但他处理得并不一定很好。这就是北爱尔兰日益严重的暴力事件。这始于60年代中期。这不是一个关于北爱尔兰动乱的播客，但我们只给你一点背景。这始于60年代中期，北爱尔兰天主教和新教社区之间的社区间暴力。英国政府在1969年派出了军队，实际上是为了保护天主教社区免受新教暴徒的伤害。但到70年代初，与天主教徒的关系已经破裂。
So 1972, this Bloody Sunday, isn't there, where paras fire on protesters? Exactly. But even before that, they had instituted a curfew, which had been very unpopular. They had interned people without trial, which had been incredibly unpopular. And by 1972, you have in that year, almost 500 people killed. You basically have a low-level civil war going in in part of the United Kingdom. And Heath is spending enormous amounts of time trying to sort it out, trying to find a solution. Doing that thing that you talked about, Tom, trying to get people around the conference table. Why can't we hammer all this out and just chat about it and find a plan to get us through it? As always with Heath, he thinks there's maybe
所以1972年，发生了“血腥星期日”，不是吗？伞兵向抗议者开火？正是如此。但在此之前，他们已经实施了宵禁，这非常不受欢迎。他们未经审判就拘留了人，这非常不受欢迎。到1972年，那一年有近500人死亡。你基本上在联合王国的一部分进行着一场低强度的内战。希思花费了大量时间试图解决这个问题，试图找到一个解决方案。做你谈到的那件事，汤姆，试图让人们围坐在会议桌旁。为什么我们不能把这一切敲定，聊一聊，找到一个计划来度过难关？像往常一样，希思认为也许
some sort of committee room fix. But I mean, you say in your book that he's trying to sort, you know, as you say, a kind of low level civil war in the UK, but he just doesn't have time because he also has millions of other things to worry about. Because he's got Europe, he's got his counties to reorganise. And of course he's got a problem with the unions. Yes. I mean, this actually is the thing that dominates the news in Britain in the early 1970s. To an extent, I think that people born subsequently, you know, who've grown up in a very different world would find almost inconceivable. You know, every day there are stories on the front page of the papers about strikes, about
会有某种委员会式的解决方案。但我的意思是，你在书中说他试图解决，你知道，正如你所说，英国的一种低强度内战，但他只是没有时间，因为他还有数百万其他事情要担心。因为他有欧洲，他有他的郡县要重组。当然，他还有工会的问题。是的。我的意思是，这实际上是70年代初英国新闻的主导事件。在某种程度上，我认为后来出生的人，你知道，在完全不同的世界中长大的人，会觉得几乎不可思议。你知道，每天报纸头版都有关于罢工、关于
negotiations. There are the scenes on the news that you and I would have grown up with, Tom, of people kind of endlessly trooping in and out of number 10. Well, again, in the stage of emergency, you're right. Burly men with steel grey hair and thick glasses were forever trooping in and out of number 10, shaking their heads sorrowfully at what their members would think of the government's latest offer.
谈判的故事。新闻里有你和我都会长大的场景，汤姆，人们没完没了地进出10号。嗯，同样，在《紧急状态》中，你是对的。留着钢灰色头发、戴着厚眼镜的魁梧男人永远在进出10号，为他们的成员对政府最新提议的看法而悲伤地摇头。
Well, that's how it worked. That's what happened. People used to describe this as the beer and sandwiches. Remember the phrase? Yeah, of course. People would always talk about them going in for beer and sandwiches with the prime minister. It never was beer and sandwiches, but they would pretend it was for their members' benefit because they didn't want to seem like it was smoked salmon and white wine, which it was.
嗯，这就是它的运作方式。这就是发生的事情。人们过去常把这描述为“啤酒和三明治”。还记得这个短语吗？是的，当然。人们总是谈论他们进去和首相喝啤酒吃三明治。从来都不是啤酒和三明治，但他们会假装是为了成员的利益，因为他们不想看起来像是烟熏三文鱼和白葡萄酒，而事实确实如此。
In the press, generally, it was thought the unions were much too powerful. So they had about 13 million members, and it was often said they were more powerful than elected politicians. Actually, I could spend hours going into the details of all this, but I think there was an argument that they were actually much too weak. There are a thousand trade unions in Britain, small, fragmented, always squabbling with each other, competing with each other. So it wasn't like Germany, West Germany, where you had a few very, very strong unions and the government could do a deal with them and know that it would stick. In Britain, you would do a deal with one union and the next day another union would pop up. So it's like fighting the Hydra.
在媒体中，人们普遍认为工会太强大了。所以他们有大约1300万成员，人们常说他们比民选政治家更强大。实际上，我可以花几个小时深入研究所有这些细节，但我认为有一种论点认为他们实际上太弱了。英国有一千个工会，规模小、分散，总是互相争吵，互相竞争。所以这不像西德，在那里你有几个非常、非常强大的工会，政府可以和他们达成协议，并知道它会坚持下去。在英国，你会和一个工会达成协议，第二天另一个工会就会冒出来。所以这就像在和九头蛇战斗。
Exactly. Our flankets would attract members by making a more extravagant demand. But Dominic, having said that, there are a few unions that are incredibly powerful because they're in a position basically to put their boot on the throat of the economy, to sound like a Daily Telegraph leader. So the railways would be one, but the biggest one is the miners. Yes. Well, the miners have been very quiescent for years, actually, since the general strike of 1926. And then in 1972, they went on strike for more money. And they said quite reasonably, our members' pay has fallen massively behind other workers. And our members have not joined
正是如此。我们的侧翼会通过提出更奢侈的要求来吸引成员。但多米尼克，话虽如此，有几个工会非常强大，因为他们基本上有能力把靴子踩在经济的喉咙上，听起来像《每日电讯报》的社论。所以铁路是一个，但最大的是矿工。是的。嗯，矿工多年来一直非常安静，实际上自1926年大罢工以来。然后在1972年，他们为了更多的钱举行了罢工。他们相当合理地说，我们成员的工资已经远远落后于其他工人。而我们的成员没有加入
in all this sort of excitement of the 1960s, the Carnaby Street kind of stuff. They're miles away and they haven't got enough money. And we would like a fair deal. And the government thought, well, we can stand up to the miners on this. Important to hold the line against inflation. And they lost. The miners basically choked the power stations of supplies of fuel. And Ted Heath had to give in. And there's huge public sympathy for the miners, isn't there? Yeah.
所有这些60年代的兴奋，那种卡纳比街的东西。他们离得很远，钱也不够。我们想要一个公平的交易。政府认为，好吧，我们可以在这个问题上对抗矿工。坚持对抗通货膨胀的底线很重要。但他们输了。矿工基本上切断了发电站的燃料供应。泰德·希思不得不屈服。公众对矿工有巨大的同情，不是吗？是的。
Their job is dangerous. Exactly. But Heath is addicted to this idea, so popular in the 70s, not just in Britain, but in the US. Nixon did it as well, for example, of incomes policies. So with inflation rising, he thinks that rather than have mass unemployment, it would be much better to have government mandated limits on how much people can earn and actually how much people pay in the shop. So it's all kinds of pay boards and price commissions. At the end of 1973, and this will be a sort of ticking time bomb for
他们的工作很危险。正是如此。但希思沉迷于这个在70年代非常流行的想法，不仅在英国，在美国也是如此。尼克松也做了，例如，收入政策。所以随着通货膨胀的上升，他认为与其大规模失业，不如由政府强制限制人们的收入以及人们在商店支付的价格。所以这全是各种工资委员会和价格委员会。1973年底，这将成为
the rest of this week, he unleashes what he calls stage three. Which doesn't sound good, does it? I mean, it sounds like a kind of medical condition. It does. Yes, it does. So stage three, your pay increase is limited to £2.25 a week, 7% a year. There's all kinds of exceptions. There's appendices. It's incredibly bureaucratic. There will be people going into companies. You run a decent sized business, ball bearing company. People would come in and they'd say, well, how much are you paying your workers? You can't pay them more than that. You can't offer them a bonus. You can't do all this. So it's very, very top down statist corporatist. But Heath was convinced that this would stop inflation.
本周余下时间的定时炸弹，他发布了他所谓的“第三阶段”。听起来不太好，不是吗？我的意思是，它听起来像是一种医疗状况。确实。是的，确实。所以第三阶段，你的工资增长限制在每周2.25英镑，每年7%。有各种各样的例外。有附录。它非常官僚。会有人员进入公司。你经营一家规模不错的企业，滚珠轴承公司。人们会进来，他们会说，好吧，你给工人付多少钱？你不能付给他们超过这个数。你不能给他们奖金。你不能做所有这些。所以它是非常、非常自上而下的国家主义法团主义。但希思确信这将阻止通货膨胀。
Can I just ask you though, the Tories at this point are not really free market then, so as they will become, the idea that you let the market determine what wages and so on should be. I mean, this is a massive issue, Tom. So basically, no, but there are some Tories, most famously a chap called Enoch Powell, who thinks Ted Heath is sold out. We are meant to be a free market party. What the hell's going on? This is socialism. So there are a few people who are giving Ted Heath grief for this, but all your ex-tank commanders with the massive glasses, they're in favour of it. They say, well, it has to be done. They're very world weary and they just sort of say, well, this is the way of the world. We don't terribly like it, but it is what it is. So in that stage three, one quick thing I'll
我能问你一下吗，保守党在这一点上并不是真正的自由市场，就像他们后来会变成的那样，即让市场决定工资等等的想法。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题，汤姆。所以基本上，不是，但有一些保守党人，最著名的是一个叫伊诺克·鲍威尔的人，他认为泰德·希思出卖了。我们本应是自由市场政党。到底发生了什么？这是社会主义。所以有几个人在为此给泰德·希思找麻烦，但你所有那些戴着大眼镜的前坦克指挥官，他们都赞成。他们说，好吧，必须这样做。他们非常厌倦世界，他们只是说，好吧，这就是世界的方式。我们不太喜欢它，但事实就是如此。所以在那个第三阶段，我提一件事，
mention, which is talking of ticking time bonds. As a sweetener for the unions, Heath says, listen, under this pay restriction thing, if inflation goes above a certain level, we'll have what we call threshold payments. So your pay will go up automatically along with it. Now, a lot of people think that's very inflationary. Prices go up, your pay goes up automatically. I mean, that's a recipe for runaway inflation. But he's very confident that inflation won't go up. All his experts are saying, what could possibly go wrong? Oil prices aren't going to suddenly go through the roof at the end of 1973. So this is a lovely little sweetener for the trade unions, and you'll never have to deliver on it. And at the same time as he's brought that policy in, simultaneously his Chancellor, Anthony Barber, has embarked on what becomes known as the Barber boom.
这提到了定时炸弹。作为给工会的甜头，希思说，听着，在这个工资限制下，如果通货膨胀超过一定水平，我们将有我们所谓的“门槛支付”。所以你的工资会随着它自动上涨。现在，很多人认为这非常具有通货膨胀性。物价上涨，工资自动上涨。我的意思是，那是通货膨胀失控的秘诀。但他非常自信通货膨胀不会上升。他所有的专家都说，能出什么错？石油价格不会在1973年底突然飙升。所以这对工会来说是一个可爱的小甜头，你永远不必兑现它。与此同时，在他实施该政策的同时，他的财政大臣安东尼·巴伯也开始了后来被称为“巴伯繁荣”的政策。
And this goes so well that you will describe Barber as having endured perhaps the roughest, worst judged and unluckiest ride of any chancellor since the war. So basically, Barber's attempt to dash for growth, it's called, isn't it? Yeah. Goes spectacularly wrong. I hate to say this, Tom, but Anthony Barber, he was a very sort of mild-mannered, balding, looked like a provincial accountant. Presumably had won the VC, had he? Yeah. He made Kwasi Kwarteng look like an absolute financial genius.
这进行得如此顺利，以至于你会形容巴伯经历了战后任何财政大臣中最艰难、判断最差、最倒霉的旅程。所以基本上，巴伯试图冲刺增长，是这样叫的，对吧？是的。错得离谱。我不想这么说，汤姆，但安东尼·巴伯，他是一个非常温和、秃顶、看起来像地方会计的人。大概他赢得了维多利亚十字勋章，是吗？是的。他让夸西·克沃滕看起来像个绝对的金融天才。
So he poured all this money into the economy and they said, it's fine because the incomes policy will keep inflation down. So it's kind of win-win. Well, there is at least one union that doesn't want to accept any restrictions on its pay. And that's the National Union of Mine Workers that we talked about earlier. That had a quarter of a million members. Obviously they've had their strike already in the Heath's premiership and won. and in the late summer joe gormley who was the leader of the num national union of mine workers who's this sort of craggy lancastrian you know looks like he was kind of born in a mine but is actually very pragmatic and essentially secretly feeding information to special branch about his own union would you believe i mean there's that sort of ludicrousness of british politics in the 70s
所以他把所有这些钱投入经济，他们说，没关系，因为收入政策会抑制通货膨胀。所以这是一种双赢。嗯，至少有一个工会不想接受任何工资限制。那就是我们之前谈到的全国矿工工会。它有25万名成员。显然，他们在希思的首相任期内已经罢工过一次，并且赢了。在夏末，乔·戈姆利，全国矿工工会的领导人，这个看起来像是在矿井里出生，但实际上非常务实，基本上秘密向特别分部提供关于他自己工会的信息的人，你敢相信吗？我的意思是，70年代英国政治就是有那种荒谬感。
yeah he's informing on his own union yeah he goes to see heath and he says you know listen ted you've got to give me something all this kind of thing they come up with a wheeze that he's going to give them kind of special payments and then disastrously heath and barbara say that's open to all the unions. Everyone can have the special payments. And Gormley's like, oh, we need to have something just for us, special. And his members say they would like a 35% pay increase. And because it's increasingly militant, the miners' union, Gormley can't really stand up to them. And actually, why would he want to? Getting a big deal for his members is in his remit.
是的，他在举报自己的工会。是的，他去见希思，他说，你知道，听着，泰德，你必须给我点什么，所有这些东西。他们想出了一个妙招，他要给他们某种特殊支付，然后灾难性的是，希思和巴伯说，这对所有工会开放。每个人都可以有特殊支付。戈姆利说，哦，我们需要有专门针对我们的东西，特殊的。他的成员说他们想要35%的工资增长。而且因为矿工工会越来越激进，戈姆利真的无法对抗他们。而且实际上，他为什么要这样做？为他的成员争取大额交易在他的职权范围内。
It's his job. Right, because it's not his job to keep the economy on track. No. So here's the thing. The big mistake that Heath and people like Heath were always making is they would get the union leaders in. The union leaders would be very jolly. Heath would play the piano for them, Tom.
这是他的工作。没错，因为保持经济运行不是他的工作。不。所以这就是问题所在。希思和像希思这样的人总是犯的一个大错误是，他们会把工会领导人叫来。工会领导人会非常快乐。希思会为他们弹钢琴，汤姆。
Yeah. He would actually play like the red flag on the piano. Have a knees up. Yeah. It would be great fun. They'd have a great laugh. They'd all be sitting around telling their war stories and stuff. And Heath would say, listen, it's in the national interest for you to have a pay rise of 4% or something.
是的。他实际上会在钢琴上弹《红旗歌》。来一场狂欢。是的。那会很有趣。他们会笑得很开心。他们都会坐在一起讲述他们的战争故事之类的。希思会说，听着，为了国家利益，你们加薪4%左右是符合国家利益的。
And the union leaders would sort of say, well, that's fine. But it's actually my job to ask you for 25%. And if I don't do that, I'll be kicked out. Yeah. And they'll get somebody who does do it. So you need to understand where we're coming from. And I think Heath couldn't do that because he was such a technocrat he just and because you know the school spirit and stuff well he's a kind of one nation tory they call it isn't it yes the idea that we're all in it together exactly we all rally around and he doesn't get that actually people
工会领导人会说，好吧，那很好。但实际上我的工作是向你要求25%。如果我不这样做，我就会被赶走。是的。他们会找一个会这样做的人。所以你需要理解我们的立场。我认为希思做不到，因为他是一个技术官僚，他只是……而且因为，你知道，学校精神之类的，嗯，他是一个所谓的“一国保守党”，是这样叫的，对吧？是的，我们都在一起的想法。正是如此，我们都团结起来，他不明白实际上人们
don't want to rally around they just want the best for themselves yeah So against this backdrop, they asked for 35%. And then we said, what could possibly go wrong? Four days before the coal board had come back to the miners with their counteroffer, which was about 16% or so. So four days before that, on the 6th of October, 1973,
不想团结起来，他们只是想要对自己最好的东西。是的。所以在这个背景下，他们要求35%。然后我们说，能出什么错？煤炭委员会回到矿工那里提出他们的还价之前四天，大约是16%左右。所以在那之前四天，1973年10月6日，
would you believe it, Tom? The Arab nations, so Egypt and Syria, had launched a stunning surprise attack on Israel, launching the Yom Kippur War. The war rages for 10 days. The Americans are airlifting supplies to the Israelis and to punish them, the OPEC oil producers announce a 70% increase in the price of oil. Ouch. So we did an episode on the consequences of this, didn't we? The oil shock of 73. But it hits Britain peculiarly hard, even though actually, I mean,
你敢相信吗，汤姆？阿拉伯国家，埃及和叙利亚，对以色列发动了惊人的突然袭击，发起了赎罪日战争。战争持续了10天。美国人向以色列人空运物资，为了惩罚他们，欧佩克石油生产国宣布石油价格上涨70%。哎哟。所以我们做了一集关于这个后果的节目，不是吗？73年的石油冲击。但它对英国的打击特别严重，尽管实际上，我的意思是，
Britain relative to America gets off more lightly, don't they? Because the Arab nations see Britain as being quite pro-Arab. Yes, they do. But it's still, it's as though, I mean, one historian says it's as though the whole country had awarded itself a 20% pay rise overnight. That's the injection of inflation by the massive increase in oil prices. And that thing that I mentioned under stage three, the threshold payments kick in. They kick in 11 times in three months or something like that. So more and more inflation is kind of pouring into the economy, if that's the right metaphor. So that is a huge, huge boost for the miners because the oil crisis gives them this weapon. The government can't rely on cheap imported oil for its power stations.
英国相对于美国来说处境要轻松一些，不是吗？因为阿拉伯国家认为英国相当亲阿拉伯。是的，确实如此。但这仍然让人感觉，我的意思是，一位历史学家说，这就像整个国家一夜之间给自己加薪了20%。这就是石油价格大幅上涨所带来的通货膨胀注入。还有我提到的第三阶段的那件事，门槛支付机制开始生效。它们在三个月内生效了11次左右。所以，如果这个比喻恰当的话，越来越多的通货膨胀正涌入经济体系。这对矿工来说是一个巨大、巨大的推动，因为石油危机给了他们这个武器。政府无法再依赖廉价的进口石油来维持其发电站的运转。
The government needs coal. And once again, as in 1972, they can cut off the supplies. And if they want to, effectively, they can plunge Britain into darkness. So the end of October, about nine, 10 days after the OPEC oil shock, the miners' union calls for industrial action. They launched initially what they used to do. The thing that you all saw in the papers in the 70s, an overtime ban. So that was always the first step. And so on the 13th of November, for the fifth time in three years, Tom, I mean, it's mind boggling now, the government announces a state of emergency in Britain. They ban the use of power in advertising, electric advertising. They order public buildings to limit their use
政府需要煤炭。而再一次，就像1972年一样，他们可以切断供应。如果他们愿意，他们实际上可以让英国陷入黑暗。所以10月底，也就是欧佩克石油冲击发生大约9、10天后，矿工工会号召采取工业行动。他们最初发起了他们过去常做的那种行动。你们在70年代的报纸上都看到过的那种事，加班禁令。所以这总是第一步。于是，11月13日，三年内第五次，汤姆，我的意思是，现在想来真是令人难以置信，政府宣布英国进入紧急状态。他们禁止在广告中使用电力，即电子广告。他们命令公共建筑限制用电。
of electricity. They start to print ration cards, Tom, for petrol because they're so worried about forecourts being jammed with people desperate to fill up. Meanwhile, the British economy, into which all this money has been poured, is absolutely tanking. So Britain is not exporting enough and it's spending tons of money on imports. So the Bank of England has to announce this huge credit squeeze. So in other words, if you're using a credit card, you will be forced every month to pay back ever greater amounts of your balance because they're desperate to stamp out borrowing. And the sort of parallel story to all this is that the Queen's daughter is getting married. So on the 14th of November,
他们开始印制汽油配给卡，汤姆，因为他们非常担心加油站会被急于加油的人挤爆。与此同时，被注入了所有这些资金的英国经济正在彻底崩溃。所以英国出口不足，却在进口上花费了巨额资金。因此，英格兰银行不得不宣布进行大规模的信贷紧缩。换句话说，如果你在使用信用卡，你每个月将被迫偿还更大比例的余额，因为他们急于遏制借贷。而这一切的平行故事是女王的女儿要结婚了。所以11月14日，
Wednesday, the 14th of November, Tom, you probably remember this. No, of course I don't. What was I then? I was six. Six in front of the TV. I was five. I was five. Fizzing with excitement as you watch the wedding of Princess Anne and Captain Mark Phillips.
11月14日星期三，汤姆，你可能还记得这件事。不，我当然不记得。那时我几岁？我六岁。六岁坐在电视机前。我五岁。我五岁。看着安妮公主和马克·菲利普斯上尉的婚礼，兴奋得不得了。
No, I was busy reading about dinosaurs. What a moment. And if you'd read the Times that day, you would have seen the cheery headline on the wedding day their special wedding edition the headline said um lights go out as emergency powers bite and then all the way down the front page there was a list of subheadings bank lending rate soars bank curbs wall street losses power plea rejected flood lights off ambulance ban hospitals under threat and all this kind of thing. So it's incredibly, incredibly gloomy.
不，我当时正忙着读关于恐龙的书。真是个难忘的时刻。如果你那天读了《泰晤士报》，你会看到婚礼当天那份特别婚礼版上欢快的头条新闻，标题写着“紧急权力生效，灯光熄灭”，然后整个头版下方列出了一系列副标题：银行贷款利率飙升、银行限制、华尔街亏损、电力请求被拒、泛光灯关闭、救护车禁令、医院受到威胁等等。所以这真是令人难以置信的阴郁。
And Heath calls in the miners at the end of that month, and he says, basically begs them, please don't do this. What can I give you? And there's a little man who says to him, and I always think this is an amazing line. He says, Prime Minister, what I don't understand is this. He says, you've told us we've got no option but to pay the Arabs the price they're demanding for oil. Now, as far as I know, he says, the Arabs didn't help us in World War I. Actually, they kind of did, but we'll forget about that.
希思在那个月底召见了矿工，他基本上是在恳求他们，请不要这样做。我能给你们什么？有个小个子男人对他说，我一直觉得这是一句了不起的话。他说，首相，我不明白的是这一点。他说，你告诉我们，除了支付阿拉伯人要求的石油价格外，我们别无选择。据我所知，他说，阿拉伯人在第一次世界大战中并没有帮助我们。实际上，他们确实帮了一些，但我们先不提这个。
And they didn't help us in World War II. We miners, we flogged our guts out and all that. And he says, why can't you pay us for coal? Well, you're prepared to pay the Arabs for oil. Heath doesn't have an answer. I mean, you can't run cars on coal, can you? No. I mean, that would be the obvious answer.
他们在第二次世界大战中也没有帮助我们。我们矿工，我们拼了老命干活，诸如此类。他说，为什么你不能为煤炭付钱给我们？好吧，你愿意为石油付钱给阿拉伯人。希思没有答案。我的意思是，你不能用煤炭来驱动汽车，对吧？不能。我的意思是，那会是显而易见的答案。
Okay. So you should have been in the meeting. I should. Because Heath says nothing. He just sits there very mutely and miserably. And then at the very end of the meeting, he says to the Scottish miners leader, Mick McGarvey, He's this kind of gravel voice, Glaswegian communist. And Heath says, what is it you want, Mr. McGarvey? And McGarvey says, I want to see the end of your government.
好吧。那你当时应该在会议上。我应该在。因为希思什么也没说。他只是非常沉默且痛苦地坐在那里。然后在会议快结束时，他对苏格兰矿工领袖米克·麦加维说，他是一个有着沙哑嗓音的格拉斯哥共产主义者。希思说，你想要什么，麦加维先生？麦加维说，我想看到你的政府倒台。
And on that bombshell time, I think we'll take a break. Wow. Things are looking bad for Heath. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. Wow. Things are looking bad for Heath. For more episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. He was a terrible speaker. He was preposterously rude and grumpy. He was far too impatient. He tried to do too much too quickly. And he was insensitive to the values and pressures that drove other people. It is worth pointing out,
在那枚重磅炸弹之后，我想我们该休息一下了。哇。希思的情况看起来很糟糕。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。哇。希思的情况看起来很糟糕。想收听更多剧集并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。他是个糟糕的演说家。他粗鲁且暴躁得离谱。他太没耐心了。他试图在太短的时间内做太多的事情。而且他对驱动他人的价值观和压力不敏感。值得指出的是，
however, that he was also incredibly unlucky. No PM since Ramsay MacDonald had been dealt such a terrible hand. So that Dominic is a top historian of the 1970s, namely yourself, writing in State of Emergency, your wonderful book on the Heath government, on Edward Heath. So he's a bad prime minister in all kinds of ways. He kind of gets things wrong. He introduces terrible policies. But as you say, the effect of these terrible policies is massively ratcheted up by bad luck. And you were describing before the break how his economic policies get kind of turbocharged into a kind of doom spiral by the huge misfortune of the Yom Kippur War and the resulting spike in oil prices. Yeah, I think maybe when you said they're all terrible policies and whatnot, I mean, they're very well-intentioned policies by and large.
然而，他也非常不幸。自拉姆齐·麦克唐纳以来，没有哪位首相拿到过如此糟糕的牌。所以，多米尼克，作为1970年代的顶级历史学家，也就是你自己，在你的精彩著作《紧急状态》中，关于希思政府和爱德华·希思的描写。所以他在各方面都是个糟糕的首相。他总是把事情搞砸。他推行了糟糕的政策。但正如你所说，这些糟糕政策的影响因厄运而大大加剧了。你在休息前描述了他的经济政策是如何因为赎罪日战争和随之而来的油价飙升这一巨大不幸，而被涡轮增压成一种毁灭螺旋的。是的，我想也许当你说是所有糟糕的政策之类的时，我的意思是，总的来说，这些政策的初衷是非常好的。
I mean, of course, the place that he wants to get to, which is a sort of more modern, more streamlined, more efficient Britain, I think is a place that's not totally unreasonable. And at the time, as it were, sensible, centrist kind of people, the rest is politics people, Tom. They were all over Heath's policies. Right. So he's facing this real problem, late 1973, that pay rises for numbers of people across the British economy are rising massively because of this background of rising prices turbocharged by the oil spike. So what are Heath's options? Well, I mean, his first thing that he has to deal with is the miners' strike, or the looming miners' strike. They're not fully out on strike at the moment.
我的意思是，当然，他想达到的目标，即一个更现代、更精简、更高效的英国，我认为这个目标并非完全不合理。而且在当时，可以说，理性的、中间派的人，也就是“剩下的就是政治”那一派的人，汤姆。他们非常支持希思的政策。对。所以他面临着一个真正的问题，1973年底，英国经济中许多人的工资涨幅因为物价上涨的背景，再加上石油价格飙升的涡轮增压，而大幅上升。那么希思有什么选择呢？好吧，我的意思是，他首先要处理的是矿工罢工，或者说即将到来的矿工罢工。他们目前还没有完全罢工。
They've got this 35% demand. Now, he could just give in to them because that's what you do with trade unions. You appease them. What I would call the rest is politics approach, which is out of centrist kindness, Tom, he could give the miners a better deal. Now, almost everybody in his government thinks that's a very bad idea because that would just encourage other unions. Does Heath have the sense of obligation to the miners that lots of people have? Yes. The sense that they are a special case? To some degree he does. This is why he's very bad at politicising the crisis, actually, because some of his younger aides say to him, listen, you want to ratchet this up.
他们有35%的加薪要求。现在，他本可以向他们屈服，因为这就是你对待工会的方式。你安抚他们。我会称之为“剩下的就是政治”的方法，也就是出于中间派的善意，汤姆，他本可以给矿工更好的待遇。现在，他政府里的几乎每个人都认为这是一个非常糟糕的主意，因为那只会鼓励其他工会。希思对矿工有很多人所拥有的那种义务感吗？有的。那种认为他们是一个特殊群体的感觉？在某种程度上他是有的。这就是为什么他实际上非常不擅长将危机政治化，因为他的一些年轻助手对他说，听着，你得把这件事升级。
The enemy within. The enemy within. You do a Margaret Thatcher. You want to turn this into the elected government versus Bolshevik agitators. Because Mick McGarvey, who you ended with, I mean, he is a communist. Yeah. There are quite a few communists in the trade unions. So Jack Jones, who was the most powerful trade unionist in the land, he was the leader of the Transport and General Workers Union. He had been an absolute card-carrying communist.
内部的敌人。内部的敌人。你要像玛格丽特·撒切尔那样做。你想把这变成民选政府与布尔什维克煽动者之间的对决。因为米克·麦加维，你刚才提到的那个人，我的意思是，他是个共产主义者。是的。工会里确实有不少共产主义者。所以杰克·琼斯，他是这个国家最有权势的工会主义者，他是运输和通用工人联盟的领袖。他曾是一个彻头彻尾的共产党员。
Well, Jack Jones, you quote a fellow union leader describing him that he had a smile glinting like the sunlight on the brass plate of a coffin. Oh, God, that's harsh. Actually, Jack Jones is very pragmatic and a very impressive man in some ways. Anyway, that's by the by. So yes, he has a sense of paternalism. I think it's fair to say he really does believe in consensus, Tom. One nation.
嗯，杰克·琼斯，你引用了一位工会领袖对他的描述，说他的微笑像阳光照在棺材的铜牌上一样闪烁。哦，天哪，那太刻薄了。实际上，杰克·琼斯在某些方面非常务实，是一个令人印象深刻的人。总之，那是题外话。所以是的，他有一种家长式作风。我认为公平地说，他确实相信共识，汤姆。一个国家。
Yeah. Yeah, one nation. Now, there are some of his aides who say, listen, we can't win. Why don't we plead special circumstances and give in to the miners? Just bite the bullet. Say it's a special case, the oil shock, energy a big issue, all this. But there are loads of people who then say, hey, you can't give in. You can't keep giving in to the union. So there are lots of mandarins who say this. Actually, people in the Labour Party who say it. So Heath's old Oxford friend, Roy Jenkins, he goes around saying to people, he's a big wig in the Labour Party, he goes around saying, Ted can't give in. Because if Ted gives in to the miners, next week it'll be the dockers, it'll be the railway men, it'll be somebody else. You just have to stand firm.
是的。是的，一个国家。现在，他的一些助手说，听着，我们赢不了。为什么我们不以特殊情况为由向矿工让步呢？咬咬牙算了。说这是一个特殊情况，石油冲击，能源是一个大问题，诸如此类。但有很多人说，嘿，你不能让步。你不能一直向工会让步。所以有很多高官这么说。实际上，工党里也有人这么说。所以希思在牛津的老朋友罗伊·詹金斯，他到处对人说，他是工党的大人物，他到处说，泰德不能让步。因为如果泰德向矿工让步，下周就会是码头工人，再下周是铁路工人，然后是其他人。你必须立场坚定。
And actually, some of Heath's aides say to him, even at this stage, have an election. Have an election on this single issue. Do you support the government or do you support the miners? Stand up for the elected government. And so one of the people who's pressing that is Nigel Lawson, isn't it? Who will go on to become Mrs. Thatcher's chancellor. Yes, yes. And best known today probably as the father of Nigella Lawson. That's right. So Nigel Lawson is part of this little group of young, it seems odd for us, Tom, to think of them as young Turks.
实际上，希思的一些助手甚至在这个阶段就对他说，举行选举吧。就这个问题举行选举。你支持政府还是支持矿工？支持民选政府。所以推动这一点的其中一个人是奈杰尔·劳森，对吧？他后来成为了撒切尔夫人的财政大臣。是的，是的。今天最出名的身份可能是奈杰拉·劳森的父亲。没错。所以奈杰尔·劳森是这群年轻人的小团体的一部分，对我们来说，汤姆，把他们看作“青年土耳其党人”似乎很奇怪。
I know. Nigella Lawson, Douglas Heard, William Wargrave, because they were Thatcherite ministers. They were Margaret Thatcher's ministers in the 1980s. But at the time, they're sort of 25. And they're saying, come on, let's have a bare knuckle fight with the unions. Let's have a crack at the unions.
我知道。奈杰拉·劳森、道格拉斯·赫德、威廉·沃格雷夫，因为他们是撒切尔派的部长。他们是玛格丽特·撒切尔在80年代的部长。但在当时，他们大约25岁。他们说，来吧，让我们和工会进行一场赤手空拳的搏斗。让我们给工会一点颜色看看。
Exactly. But he does nothing. He's very passive. He's very kind of weary. He's got a thyroid complaint, hasn't he? He does. Undiagnosed. Undiagnosed. So he's becoming enormously fat as well. People keep saying, God, he's getting fat. I mean, ironically, he's suffering inflation. He's inflating, yeah, ironically. But also he's becoming more and more miserable.
完全正确。但他什么也没做。他非常被动。他非常疲惫。他患有甲状腺疾病，不是吗？是的。未确诊。未确诊。所以他也变得非常肥胖。人们一直说，天哪，他越来越胖了。我的意思是，讽刺的是，他正在遭受通货膨胀。他正在膨胀，是的，讽刺的是。但他也变得越来越痛苦。
So he'll have meetings with the union leaders where he just says nothing at all and just looks like he's going to cry. Well, he must be shattered. I mean, he's had so many problems. I forgot to mention there's also a train strike. Yes, of course there is. And also Northern Ireland's really bad. So there's loads of stuff going on.
所以他会和工会领袖开会，但他什么都不说，看起来就像要哭出来一样。好吧，他一定崩溃了。我的意思是，他遇到了太多的问题。我忘了提还有火车罢工。是的，当然有。而且北爱尔兰的情况也非常糟糕。所以有很多事情正在发生。
It's all very miserable. On the 12th of December, a crucial day, two things happen. First of all, his Chancellor, Anthony Barber, who's also shattered and looking very harassed, like a kind of very miserable vicar. Anthony Barber sends a report to all his cabinet colleagues and he says, we're now facing the gravest economic crisis since the end of the war. We've got no coal, we can't afford to buy any oil, inflation's through the roof, we're borrowing too much money, nobody abroad has got any confidence in the pound. And he says, we're going to have to scrap all our plans for spending. So Heath's education secretary, Tom, has a very ambitious plan out of kindness to increase.
一切都非常悲惨。12月12日，关键的一天，两件事发生了。首先，他的财政大臣安东尼·巴伯，他也崩溃了，看起来非常憔悴，像一个非常悲惨的牧师。安东尼·巴伯给所有的内阁同事发了一份报告，他说，我们现在面临着战后最严重的经济危机。我们没有煤炭，我们买不起石油，通货膨胀严重，我们借了太多的钱，国外没有人对英镑有信心。他说，我们将不得不废除我们所有的支出计划。所以希思的教育大臣，汤姆，出于善意，有一个非常雄心勃勃的计划来增加。
Despite having snatched the milk from the poor little children. To increase nursery provision and to expand universities. And that person is Margaret Thatcher. And Barber says, that's got to go. Can't do it. It's no money. So there's that. And then at five o'clock that afternoon, having all read this incredibly depressing memo, they meet to discuss what they're going to do about the power situation. And they basically say, we're going to have to take incredibly drastic measures. So we're going to have to put industry, shops and offices on a three day working week. Offices will have to keep their temperatures below 63 degrees Fahrenheit. We'll
尽管从可怜的小孩子嘴里抢走了牛奶。增加托儿服务并扩大大学规模。那个人就是玛格丽特·撒切尔。巴伯说，那必须取消。做不到。没钱了。所以就是这样。然后在那天下午五点，读完这份令人极其沮丧的备忘录后，他们开会讨论如何处理电力状况。他们基本上说，我们将不得不采取极其严厉的措施。所以我们将不得不让工业、商店和办公室实行每周三天工作制。办公室必须将温度保持在华氏63度以下。我们将
cut street lighting by 50%. We will ban the use of floodlights in sport. So this is very important, isn't it? Because it's ultimately what results in football being played on Sundays. Because previously that hadn't happened? Because it's ultimately what results in football being played on Sundays. On Sundays. Because previously that hadn't happened. Yes. Because they have to move the fixtures into daytime. Yes. Had this not happened, Tom, nobody would have even heard of Manchester City. Televised football and all this kind of thing would never have happened.
将街道照明减少50%。我们将禁止在体育运动中使用泛光灯。所以这非常重要，不是吗？因为这最终导致了足球在周日进行。因为之前没有发生过这种情况？因为这最终导致了足球在周日进行。在周日。因为之前没有发生过这种情况。是的。因为他们必须把比赛移到白天进行。是的。如果这没有发生，汤姆，没人会听说过曼城。电视转播足球和所有这些事情都不会发生。
So TV has to turn off at 10.30. There's no broadcasts after 10.30 at night. And so late that afternoon, he stands up in the House of Commons and he says, this is the deal. At midnight on New Year's Eve, we're going on a three-day week. And then he gives this broadcast to the nation, which is the one that you always see in documentaries about the 70s. We shall have a harder Christmas than we've known since the war. That one.
所以电视必须在10点30分关闭。晚上10点30分之后没有广播。那天下午晚些时候，他站在下议院说，这就是协议。新年前夜午夜，我们将实行三天工作制。然后他发表了那个全国广播讲话，就是你在关于70年代的纪录片中总是看到的那个。我们将度过一个比战后任何时候都更艰难的圣诞节。就是那个。
Yeah, like the most depressing broadcast you've ever seen. Ho, ho, ho. In which the prime minister says, I want to speak to you about the grave emergency facing our country. You know, it's not Churchillian, put it that way. So Christmas comes, and Christmas is pretty awful. Because there's all this looming, the three-day week is coming. IRA bombs are going off in London, aren't they?
是的，就像你见过的最令人沮丧的广播。呵呵呵。首相在广播中说，我想和你们谈谈我们国家面临的严重紧急情况。你知道，这不是丘吉尔式的，这么说吧。所以圣诞节来了，圣诞节相当糟糕。因为所有这些迫在眉睫的事情，三天工作制即将到来。爱尔兰共和军的炸弹在伦敦爆炸，不是吗？
Right, so the IRA really now launches its campaign of bombing. There's been bombs in Belfast, by the way, or a shooting in 1972 and 1973, pretty much every single day. But now the IRA is launching its campaign on what at the time people called the British mainland. So seven days before Christmas, there are car bombs in London and Westminster, Pentonville, Hampstead, and 60 people are injured. Thankfully, nobody killed. There's an incredibly bleak mood in government. So there's a story that the Environment Secretary, Geoffrey Rippon, who's one of Heath's kind of great outriders, he has a kind of Christmas dinner party.
对，所以爱尔兰共和军现在真正发起了它的爆炸运动。顺便说一下，1972年和1973年，贝尔法斯特几乎每天都有爆炸或枪击事件。但现在爱尔兰共和军正在当时人们所说的“英国本土”发起运动。所以圣诞节前七天，伦敦和威斯敏斯特、本顿维尔、汉普斯特德发生了汽车炸弹袭击，60人受伤。谢天谢地，没有人死亡。政府内部气氛极其阴郁。所以有一个故事说，环境大臣杰弗里·里彭，他是希思的得力干将之一，他举办了一个圣诞晚宴。
And he tells everybody this dinner party, we're the Weimar Republic. Yeah. You know, that's where we are now. Well, so a lot of those parallels. Loads. And also the other parallel that people are very keen on is Chile, which has just had the coup where Allende government has been toppled by General Pinochet. Absolutely.
他在晚宴上告诉所有人，我们是魏玛共和国。是的。你知道，这就是我们现在的处境。好吧，所以有很多这样的相似之处。很多。而且人们非常热衷的另一个相似之处是智利，那里刚刚发生了政变，阿连德政府被皮诺切特将军推翻了。绝对是。
And we will come on to this even more when Harold Wilson enters the story later this week, Tom. Well, of course, the other great philosopher who comments on what Britain needs at this point is David Bowie, isn't it? Of course. Yeah. He says that Britain needs an extreme right front to come up and sweep everything off its feet and tidy everything up. That was before his White Duke phase, wasn't it?
当哈罗德·威尔逊在本周晚些时候进入故事时，我们会更多地谈到这一点，汤姆。当然，此时评论英国需要什么的另一位伟大的哲学家是大卫·鲍伊，不是吗？当然。是的。他说英国需要一个极右翼阵线出现，横扫一切，把一切清理干净。那是在他的“白公爵”阶段之前，不是吗？
Yeah. I'm afraid to say it, but it's a fascist phase. But the big hit of the year, Tom, is Merry Christmas, Everybody by Slade. They wanted to cheer everyone up, didn't they? Well, so Noddy Holder, the lead singer of Slade, was interviewed by Mojo. And he said that line, look to the future now, it's only just begun. He said he wanted to cheer everybody up.
是的。我恐怕得说，这是一个法西斯阶段。但那一年的大热门，汤姆，是斯莱德乐队的《圣诞快乐，每个人》。他们想让每个人都振作起来，不是吗？好吧，斯莱德乐队的主唱诺迪·霍尔德接受了《Mojo》杂志的采访。他说那句台词，“展望未来吧，它才刚刚开始”。他说他想让每个人都振作起来。
He said the country couldn't have been at a lower ebb. Times like that, people always turn to showbiz. He wasn't wrong. But actually, because I'm very boring and a pedant, I checked and actually they recorded the song last summer. So he couldn't have. Oh, that's the quality of research that you expect from a top historian of the 70s. I mean, how could he possibly have done it as a reaction to the three-day week?
他说这个国家不可能处于更低的低谷了。像那样的时刻，人们总是转向演艺圈。他没说错。但实际上，因为我很无聊且迂腐，我查了一下，他们实际上是去年夏天录制的这首歌。所以他不可能……哦，这就是你对70年代顶级历史学家的研究期望。我的意思是，他怎么可能把它作为对三天工作制的反应呢？
Three-day week hadn't even happened. Yeah, but maybe he saw that Heath's incomes policy was doomed. Yes, precisely. He didn't agree with incomes policies. He studied world commodity prices. He knew disaster was coming. Actually, the Queen, her Christmas message, Ted Heath rewrote her Christmas message. Because it was too damn beat.
三天工作制甚至还没发生。是的，但也许他预见到希思的收入政策注定要失败。是的，正是如此。他不同意收入政策。他研究了世界商品价格。他知道灾难即将来临。实际上，女王的圣诞致辞，泰德·希思重写了她的圣诞致辞。因为它太丧了。
Because it was too damn beat. She wanted to talk about the special difficulties that Britain is facing. And he said, no mention of difficulties. And then they rewrote it. And she said, I will not talk about the difficulties Britain is facing. And he said, still no good. And so she just had to show people princess anne's wedding photos some yeah and hadn't someone tried to abduct princess anne from yes a male or something that's right in 1974 someone tried to kidnap princess anne
因为它太丧了。她想谈谈英国面临的特殊困难。他说，不许提困难。然后他们重写了它。她说，我不会谈论英国面临的困难。他说，还是不行。所以她只能向人们展示安妮公主的婚礼照片，是的，而且不是有人试图绑架安妮公主吗？是的，一个男人什么的，没错，1974年有人试图绑架安妮公主。
and they said get out of the car or something she said not bloody likely yeah something along those lines whack them with a handbag exactly very impressive now abroad of course people have noticed that britain's going to hell in a handcart. And, you know, if you read sort of the New York Times, loves it. And Der Spiegel. The swinging London of the 60s has given way to a London as gloomy as the city described by Charles Dickens, with the once imperial streets of the capital now sparsely lighted, like the slummy streets of a former British imperial township. Oh, that's harsh. But Dominic, am I not right that somebody who had lived in the slummy streets of a former
他们说“下车”之类的，她说“想都别想”，是的，类似那样的话，用手提包打他们，完全正确，非常令人印象深刻。现在在国外，当然人们已经注意到英国正在走向毁灭。而且，你知道，如果你读《纽约时报》，它很喜欢这样。还有《明镜周刊》。60年代摇摆的伦敦已经让位于查尔斯·狄更斯所描述的那样阴郁的伦敦，曾经帝国首都的街道现在灯光稀疏，就像前英国帝国城镇贫民窟的街道一样。哦，那太刻薄了。但多米尼克，我没说错吧，一个曾经住过前英国帝国城镇贫民窟的人，也就是当时的乌干达领导人伊迪·阿明，他介入了，他说乌干达人怀着巨大的悲痛看到了英国的困境，并正在筹集资金。没错。拯救英国基金。这个故事有趣的地方在于，一方面，它太阴郁了。太令人沮丧了。太冷太黑了。
British imperial township, namely Idi Amin, the leader of Uganda at this point, steps in and he says that Ugandans have seen the plight of Britain with great sorrow in raising a fund. That's right. The Save Britain Fund. The funny thing about this story, on the one hand, it's so bleak. It's so depressing. So cold and dark.
它太搞笑了。但它也很荒谬。所以伊迪·阿明，是的，他发起了拯救英国基金。他说，我决定从我的积蓄中捐出10,000乌干达先令，我相信许多乌干达人会慷慨解囊，拯救他们在英国的无辜朋友。
It's so funny. But it is also ludicrous. So Idi Amin, yes, he launches the Save Britain Fund. He says, I've decided to contribute 10,000 Ugandan shillings for my savings and I'm convinced that many Ugandans will donate generously to rescue their innocent friends in Britain.
外交部无视了他。他们说，甚至不要回复他。不要鼓励他。然后伊迪·阿明又写信了。他说，听着，基加齐区的人们捐了一卡车蔬菜，它正停在机场的停机坪上。请派一架飞机来取。但他们再次无视了他。
The foreign office ignored him. They said, don't even reply to him. Don't encourage him. And then Idi Amin wrote again. And he said, listen, the people from the Kigazi district have donated a lorry load of vegetables and it's sitting on the tarmac at the airport. Please send a plane to come and get it. But again, they ignored him.
他开始给女王发电报说，你知道，我提出了这些善意的提议，而你完全无视它们。你对待我非常糟糕。当然，这在英国被报道了。人们并不觉得这很有趣。他们认为这是一种羞辱。他们认为阿明，那个曾经是苏格兰步枪队军官之类的人，他在嘲笑英国，这太可怕了。他们会说，你知道，他在嘲笑英国。他确实在嘲笑。而且，你知道，再也没有比这更具象征意义的提醒，说明英国的国际声望已经跌到了多低的程度。
And he started sending telegrams to the Queen to say, you know, I make these kind offers and you're completely ignoring them. You're treating me very poorly. And of course, this was reported in Britain. And people didn't think it was funny. They thought it was humiliating. They thought it was terrible that Armin, who had been an officer in the Scottish Rifles or something, that he was laughing. They would say, you know, he's laughing at Britain. And he was. And it was, you know, there could be no more emblematic reminder of how low Britain's international prestige had fallen.
与此同时，三天工作制正在生效，不是吗？是的。从新年前夜午夜开始。确实。所以我们现在进入了1974年。终于。所以汤姆，如果你在你的家乡索尔兹伯里有一家制造泰德·希思纪念品的工厂，你那家工厂只有在周一、周二、周三或者周四、周五、周六才有电。如果你有一家商店，一家泰德·希思纪念品店，你要么只有上午有电，要么只有下午有电。所以你必须选择哪一个，
Meanwhile, the three-day week is kicking in, isn't it? Yes. Begins at midnight on New Year's Eve. It does. So we're now into 1974. Finally. So Tom, if you'd had a factory in your native Salisbury making Ted Heath memorabilia, you would only have had power in that factory either Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, or Thursday, Friday, Saturday. And if you'd had a shop, a Ted Heath souvenir shop, you'd have either had power mornings or afternoons. So you'd have had to choose which,
或者你会接到通知，我不知道具体是怎么运作的。然后剩下的时间，你会点蜡烛，裹着毯子之类的，因为人们就是这样反应的。现在在左翼，很多人实际上说三天工作制是一个资本主义的诡计。激进分子到处跑着开着灯，不是吗？他们确实开着灯。所以在德比郡的克莱克罗斯，议会调高了街道照明以打倒资本主义。在电视上，当时最受欢迎的英国喜剧之一是《直到死亡将我们分开》，阿尔夫·加内特喜剧。是的，是一个扮演种族主义码头工人的家伙，是吗？他是一个住在东区的家伙。他是种族主义者。
or you'd be told which, I don't know exactly how it worked. And then for the rest of the time, you'd have kind of candles and you'd be wrapped in a blanket or something because that's how people reacted. Now on the left, lots of people actually said the three-day week is a capitalist wheeze. Radicals kind of rushing around leaving lights on, aren't they? They are leaving lights on. So in Claycross, Derbyshire, the council turned up the street lighting to bring down capitalism. On TV, one of the most popular British comedies at the time was Till Death Us Do Part, the Alf Garnet comedy. Yeah, it's a guy playing a racist docker, is he? He's a guy in the East End. He's racist.
他非常保守。所以对于我们的美国听众来说，这是《全家福》的原型，我们的美国听众会记得阿奇·邦克那个节目。在那部剧中，阿尔夫的家人到处打开所有的灯，因为他们讨厌泰德·希思。在《神秘博士》中，汤姆，《神秘博士》有一个故事叫《佩拉顿的怪物》，关于佩拉顿星球上的矿工罢工。博士实际上去了这个星球，他说，支付给矿工你们欠他们的钱。不要把矿工
He's very conservative. So for our American listeners, this was the prototype for the show All in the Family, the Archie Bunker show that our American listeners will remember. And in that show, Alf's family, they go around turning on all the lights because they hate Ted Heath. In Doctor Who, Tom, Doctor Who had a story called The Monster of Peladon about a miners' strike on the planet Peladon. And the doctor actually goes to this planet and he says, pay the miners what you owe them. Don't grind the miners
碾成尘埃。所以，在所谓的“喋喋不休的阶层”中，对矿工有很多同情，对希思有很多反感。我想他需要的是，他想让人们觉得这一切都是矿工的错，他们正在遭受可怕的匮乏，强大的工会正在关掉人们的灯，人们正在发抖。但问题难道不是灯没有熄灭，实际上这些措施奏效了吗？是的。所以人们觉得政府反应过度了。完全正确。完全正确，汤姆。所以对于听这个节目的听众，如果你记得70年代，你认为“啊，三天工作制，那些停电”，你记错了。在三天工作制期间，并没有
into the dust. So among the, as it were, the chattering classes, There's a lot of sympathy for the miners, a lot of antipathy against Heath. And what I suppose he needed was he wanted people to feel that it was all the miners' fault, that they were suffering terrible privations, that the overmighty unions were turning people's lights off and people were shivering. But isn't the problem that the lights don't go off, that actually the measures work? Yes. And so therefore people feel that the government's overreacted. Exactly so. Exactly right, Tom. So for people listening to this, if you remember the 70s and you think, ah, the three-day week, those power cuts, you are misremembering. There were not
随机、自发、意外的停电。70年代有其他时候因为电力工人罢工而停电，但实际上三天工作制是有效的。而且天气甚至没有那么冷。所以这是一个异常温暖的冬天。而且希思还有一个更复杂的因素，就是有一种轻微的“新冠效应”，人们实际上很享受不必去上班。是的，确实有一点。他们都重新发现人们实际上很享受不必去上班，是的，有
random, spontaneous, unexpected power cuts during the three-day week. There were other times in the 70s because of electricity worker strikes, but actually the three-day week works. And it's not even actually that cold. So it's an unseasonably warm winter. And isn't there also a further complication for Heath is that there's a slight kind of COVID thing that people actually quite enjoy not having to go to work. Yeah, there is a little bit. And they all kind of rediscover that people actually quite enjoy not having to go to work yeah there
一点。他们都重新发现了棋盘游戏之类的东西。他们确实这样做了。所以人们在玩棋盘游戏或者其他什么，他们点着蜡烛读书，玩着跳跳球之类的。他们确实是。我最喜欢所有这些故事中的一个，是《每日邮报》追踪到了一位心理学家或类似的人，他告诉人们，在三天工作制期间，人们应该在性生活中多做实验，当孩子们在教室里冻得发抖时，你却在家里，因为你没去上班，因为工厂没有电之类的。所以这是你的机会，非常时髦，非常时髦的行为。那篇文章，汤姆，我
is a little bit and they all kind of rediscover board games and things they do so people are playing cold it's board game or whatever they're doing and they're sort of reading by candlelight playing on their space hoppers and things they are exactly my favorite of all these stories is the daily mail of all newspapers tracked down a psychiatrist or psychologist or something very joy of sex who said to people what people should do in the three-day week is experiment more in their sex lives when when the kids are at school freezing in their classroom but you're at home because you haven't gone to work because there isn't any electricity at the factory or whatever so this is your chance very groovy very groovy behavior that article tom i
讨厌这么说，但那是在我出生前九个月发表的。好吧，你自己得出结论吧，我认为那信息量太大了。所以随着几周过去，人们变得越来越恼火。有一个关于喜剧演员肯尼思·威廉姆斯的绝妙例子，他写了一本日记，一本非常精彩的日记，实际上。我真的很推荐它。他描述了1月10日，他在火车上。火车现在又开始运行了，但很多都被取消了。所以火车上挤满了人，每个人都在抱怨。他们抱怨的不是矿工，而是政府。他在日记中写道，他说，
hate to say it but that was published nine months before i was born well so draw your own conclusions i think that's too much information there so as the weeks pass people become more and more irritated all this there's a brilliant example of this by the carry-on film actor kenneth williams who kept a diary, a wonderful diary, actually. I really recommend it to people. And he describes how on the 10th of January, he's on a train. The trains are now running again, but a lot of them have been cancelled. So the train is really crowded with people and everybody is complaining. And they're complaining not about the miners, but the government. And he writes in his diary, he says,
你在谈话中感觉到这一切已经走得太远了。三天工作制全是垃圾，应该给矿工发工资。哦，太可怕了，他说。可怕。他认为矿工应该被绞死。他讨厌矿工。他非常右翼。好吧，他还引用了某人的话，抱怨人们遵守规则，说他们像一群羊。是的。这也很有“新冠味”。非常有“新冠味”。我的意思是，人们反对口罩和封锁之类的。完全正确。而且责怪政府。实际上，他们责怪的是政府。
you feel all this in conversation that's gone too far. The three-day week is all rubbish and the miners should be paid. Oh, it's ghastly, he says. Ghastly. He thinks the miners should be hanged. He hates the miners. He's very right wing. Well, he also, he quotes somebody who complains about people kind of obeying the rules and say that they're like a load of sheep. Yes. Which is also quite COVID-y. Very COVID-y. I mean, people objecting to masks and lockdowns and things. Exactly. And blaming the government. Actually, it's the government who they blame.
所以在威斯敏斯特，泰德·希思在那里。他患有甲状腺疾病。他非常痛苦。他精疲力竭。他和他的助手们真的不知道该怎么办。然后他们得到了一根救命稻草。因为在1月9日，工会大会，也就是所有工会的伞状组织，他们来见他，他们有一位新的秘书长，他叫
So at Westminster, Ted Heath is there. He's got his thyroid complaint. He's very miserable. He's absolutely exhausted. He and his aides don't really know what to do. And then they get a lifeline. Because on the 9th of January, the trade union congress so it's the umbrella organization of all the unions they come to see him they've got a new general secretary he's called
莱恩·默里，他实际上是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，汤姆。他是什罗普郡人，对吧？所以是你的老家。是的，莱恩·默里出生于一个未婚母亲，他被一位护士收养了。他在第二次世界大战中在英国军队服役，我想是这样。然后他在伍尔弗汉普顿的一家工程工厂工作。从那里，他一路升到了牛津大学新学院。他用两年而不是三年完成了学位，并在PPE（政治、哲学和经济学）专业获得了优等成绩，然后一路升至英国工会运动的领袖。
len murray he's a very impressive man actually tom he's from shopshire isn't he so you're neck of the woods yeah and len murray had been born to an unmarried mother and he'd been sort of adopted by a nurse he fought in the british army the Second World War, I think it was. Then he worked at an engineering factory in Wolverhampton. From there, he worked his way up into New College, Oxford. He did his degree in two years, not three, and got a first in PPE, politics, philosophy, and economics, and then worked his way up to become the leader of Britain's trade union movement.
非常令人印象深刻。他是一个非常正派、温和的人。他去见巴伯，他说，听着，我们会帮你摆脱这个困境。给矿工他们想要的。我保证我们会发表声明说这是一个特殊情况，没有其他工会会利用这个作为漏洞。你知道，我们不会利用这一点。我们不会做所有这些。
Very impressive. And he's a very decent, kind of mild-mannered man. He goes to see a barber and he says, listen, we'll help you out of this. Give the miners what they want. And I promise we will issue a statement saying this is a special case and no other union will use this as a kind of loophole. You know, we won't exploit this. We won't do all this.
泰德·希思说了什么？他说，不，不。他没有做所有这些。泰德·希思说了什么？他说，不，不。他不相信给矿工他们想要的。而且，坦率地说，他不相信工会大会能兑现承诺，实际上他们可能确实做不到。但莱恩·默里本人后来也说，如果我们没有兑现，他本应该接受这笔交易，然后因为我们没有履行协议而狠狠地打击我们。他本可以以此作为他反工会政策的理由。他本应该接受这笔交易。但他认为做交易是像哈罗德·威尔逊那样卑劣的政客做的事。我不会做交易。我要坚持我的立场。
And what does Ted Heath say? He says, no, no. He doesn't do all this. And what does Ted Heath say? He says, no, no. He doesn't believe in giving the miners what they want. And also, frankly, he doesn't believe that the trade union Congress can deliver, which actually they probably couldn't. But Len Murray himself said later, if we didn't deliver, he should have just taken the deal and then just hammered us for not delivering on our side of the bargain. And he could have used this as justification for his anti-union policies. He just should have taken the deal. But he thinks doing deals is what a grubby politician like Harold Wilson does. I'm not going to do a deal. I'm going to stick to my guns.
他是一个命运之子。所以他只是坐在那里参加所有这些会议。他与这些工会领袖进行了无休止的会议。他们对他说，没有什么我们可以提供给你的能让你满意吗？他说，基本上，没有，我只是想让你们接受我提供的条件。你知道他让我想起了谁吗，汤姆？他太像特蕾莎·梅了。他缺乏微妙之处、直觉和那种冷酷的杀手本能，你知道，那种灵活性，你知道，像个战略家，像个棋盘游戏玩家之类的。所以他可能在牛津拿到了学位，多米尼克，但他没有拿到“人际关系”学位。哦，汤姆，那太深刻了。干得好。谢谢你。我很喜欢。所以他所有的助手都说，举行选举吧，解决所有问题。举行选举，在2月7日进行。所以三天工作制将全面展开。他说，好吧，我会做，我会做。但在最后一刻，他失去了勇气，他没有做
He's a man of destiny. So he's just sitting there in all these meetings. He's having endless meetings with these union leaders. And they say to him, is there nothing we can offer you that will satisfy you? And he says, basically, no, I just want you to accept what I'm offering. And do you know what he reminds me of, Tom? He's so Theresa May. He lacks the subtlety and the instincts and the killer ruthless, you know, the flexibility, you know, like a strategist, like a board games player or something. So he may have a degree from Oxford, Dominic, but he doesn't have a degree in people. Oh, Tom, that's so profound. Well done. Thank you for that. I enjoyed that. So all his aides say, call an election, just resolve the whole thing. Call an election, do it on the 7th of February. So three day week will be full swing. And he says, fine, I'll do i'll do it i'll do it and at the last minute he loses his nerve and he doesn't do
他没有举行这次提前选举，一周后，矿工们说，别再磨磨蹭蹭了，你知道，孤注一掷吧。大规模全面罢工，切断发电站的供应，就是这样，让我们干吧。罢工将在二月初开始，他现在想，哦，我毕竟应该举行那次选举。这是一个多么可怕的错误。就在这时，汤姆，是的，这是我整个故事中最喜欢的部分。所以这是，嗯，公务员主管威廉·阿姆斯特朗爵士疯了。疯了，是的。当你说是他疯了，是的，基本上他崩溃了。是的，所以这是，嗯，这是一个叫威廉·阿姆斯特朗爵士的人，所以这标志着他作为技术官僚是如何治理的，威廉·阿姆斯特朗爵士，他是公务员主管，
it he doesn't call this early election and a week later the miners say enough of the pussy footing you know let's go for broke massive all-out strike cut off the supplies to the power stations this is it kind of let's do it and the strike is going to begin at the beginning of february and he now thinks oh i should have called that election after all what a terrible mistake this has been and it's at this point tom that's yes my favorite bit in the whole story so this is um the head of the civil service sir william armstrong goes mad going mad yes and when you say he goes mad yes basically he has a breakdown yes so this is um this is a guy called sir william armstrong so it's a sign of how he governed as a technocrat that sir william armstrong who's the head of the civil service
是他的得力助手，而不是民选政客。所以威廉·阿姆斯特朗爵士是一位典型的贵族高官。他是一个委员会成员。汉弗莱·阿普尔比爵士。是的，他就像《是，大臣》里的汉弗莱爵士，尽管他更严肃，没那么
is his right hand man, not an elected politician. So Sir William Armstrong is a classic kind of patrician Mandarin. He's a committee man. Sir Humphrey Appleby. Yeah, he's like Sir Humphrey from Yes Minister, although he's sort of more serious and less right. Machiavellian. Exactly, much less Machiavellian.
马基雅维利。完全正确，没那么马基雅维利。他就像希思。他相信，你知道，为什么我们不能围坐在桌子旁，制定一个复杂的政策，用箭头来解决这个问题？是的。在一月初，他完全不知所措。他开始召开这些会议，他会把人锁在房间里说，共产主义者已经渗透了英国政府。当我们说话时，他们可能就在房间里。这实际上预示了哈罗德·威尔逊重掌权力后会发生的事情。所以让我们先搁置这个。这是本系列后面内容的预告。完全是。完全是。所以这会在后面的剧集中回来。所以人们觉得这不太好。有一个说法是他把所有的常任
He's like Heath. He believes, you know, why can't we just get around the table and draw up a complicated policy that will sort this out with arrows? Yes. And at the beginning of January, he is completely overwhelmed. And he starts having these meetings where he will kind of lock people in the room and say, the communists have infiltrated the British government. They may be in the room as we speak. Which actually is a prefiguring of what will happen with Harold Wilson when he comes back into power. So let's just park that. That's a flag for later in the series. It totally is. It totally is. So that will come back in later episodes. So people are kind of thinking this isn't good. There's one account that he gets all the permanent
秘书，也就是其他公务员大人物，都叫来，把他们锁在一个房间里，然后给他们上了一堂关于，我引用一下，“圣经和性”的课，这在你处理矿工罢工时可能不太理想。而且不是有个故事说英格兰银行行长来见他，他把衣服全脱了，躺在地板上和行长说话吗？是的，没错。所以有两个不同的故事，他正在对特许会计师协会的代表团讲话，他一边躺在地板上背朝上，一边对他们讲话。哦，对。是的。抱歉，我搞混了。另一个是，是英格兰银行行长，他把衣服全脱了，特许会计师，他一边躺在地板上背朝上，一边对他们讲话。哦，对。是的。抱歉，我搞混了。另一个是，这是英格兰银行行长，他把衣服全脱了。
secretaries, so the other civil service bigwigs, and he locks them in a room and then he gives them a huge lecture about, and I quote, the Bible and sex, which is probably not ideal when you're dealing with a minor strike. And isn't there a story that the governor of the Bank of England comes to meet him and he takes all his clothes off and is speaking to the governor lying on the floor? Yeah, that's right. So there are two different ones that he's talking to a delegation from the Institute of Chartered Accountants and he addresses them while lying on the floor on his back. Oh, right. Yeah. Sorry, I was muddling it up. And the other is, is the governor of the Bank of England, he takes all his clothes off, chartered accountants and he addresses them while lying on the floor on his back oh right yeah sorry i was muddling it up and the other is this is the governor of bank of england he takes all his clothes
秘书们，还有其他公务员高层，他把他们锁在一个房间里，然后给他们上了一堂关于——引用他的话——“圣经与性”的大课，这在处理小型罢工时可能不太合适。而且是不是有个故事说英格兰银行行长来见他，他把衣服全脱了，躺在地板上跟行长说话？是的，没错。所以有两个不同的版本，一个是他在跟特许会计师协会的代表团谈话时，躺在地板上仰面朝天跟他们讲话。哦，对。是的。抱歉，我搞混了。另一个是英格兰银行行长，他把衣服全脱了，特许会计师，他躺在地板上仰面朝天跟他们讲话，哦，对，是的，抱歉，我搞混了，另一个是英格兰银行行长，他把衣服全脱了
off his clothes not the governor's clothes that would be really peculiar right that really would be mad but either way at the end of this day that this has all come to a head basically everyone says to him you've got to take a break you know go home don't come back. So he's gone. And that gives you a sense of the unbelievably febrile, sort of hysterical mood at this point in Westminster and Whitehall. And he finally cracks and decides, I'm going to call an election. And ironically, he does it on the very day that he should have held the election. So everyone thought he should have the election on the 7th of February and he'd have probably won, but instead he calls it on the 7th of February for the 28th of February. And the one thing before we get into the election,
脱掉的是他自己的衣服，而不是州长的衣服，那真的很奇怪，对吧？那确实会让人发疯。但无论如何，在这一天结束时，当所有事情都达到顶点时，基本上每个人都对他说，你得休息一下，你知道，回家去，别再回来了。所以他走了。这让你感受到当时威斯敏斯特和白厅那种令人难以置信的狂热、近乎歇斯底里的气氛。他最终崩溃了，决定要举行选举。讽刺的是，他宣布选举的那天，正是他本该举行选举的日子。所以每个人都认为他应该在2月7日举行选举，而且他很可能会赢，但他却在2月7日宣布选举将在2月28日举行。在我们进入选举之前，有一件事，
which we'll be doing next time, is this. Why did he do it, Tom? Because his premiership still had a year to run, more than a year to run. And even if he had won the election, so what? I mean, the miners weren't going to say the next morning, oh, fine, you've won the election. Yeah, we were wrong. We'll go back to work. I mean, that was never going to happen. It's like a sort of desperation measure. Well, it seems like he couldn't think of anything else to do. Exactly. That's exactly what it was. He felt like he'd run out of options. He'd call the election. But so what? Do you think part of anything else to do. Exactly. That's exactly what it was. He felt like he'd run out of options. He'd call the election.
我们下次会讲到，那就是：汤姆，他为什么要这么做？因为他的首相任期还有一年多，不止一年。即使他赢得了选举，那又怎样？我的意思是，矿工们第二天早上不会说，哦，好吧，你赢了选举。是的，我们错了。我们会回去工作。我的意思是，这根本不可能发生。这就像是一种孤注一掷的措施。嗯，看起来他想不出别的办法了。没错。事实正是如此。他觉得他已经别无选择。他宣布了选举。但那又怎样？你认为他内心深处想输吗？
So what? Do you think part of him wanted to lose? No, I don't. I don't think he ever thought he wanted to lose. You began that beautiful reading, Tom, which I'm sure everybody enjoyed. Yeah, thank you. Where he addressed the nation, and he doesn't realise it, but it's his final time as Prime Minister.
那又怎样？你认为他内心深处想输吗？不，我不这么认为。我不认为他曾经想过要输。汤姆，你刚才那段精彩的朗读，我相信大家都听得很享受。是的，谢谢。他在那次演讲中向全国发表讲话，他自己并没有意识到，但这却是他作为首相的最后一次演讲。
And he says to them, you know, for you to decide this, do the elected government run the country or does a particularly powerful group of workers, i.e. the miners, run the country? And he's going to get the answer on the 28th of February. And it's not the answer, Tom, that he's expecting. So we will come back tomorrow with that election, the first election of 1974, where Britain is being asked to choose who governs. And we will find out tomorrow. But Tom, of course, if people are members of our very own little union, of course, the National Union of Rest is History Club members, then they will be able to hear the whole of this series. Well, they'll be able to join us for beer and sandwiches, won't they? They will indeed.
他对他们说，你知道，由你们来决定，是民选政府治理国家，还是一个特别强大的工人团体，即矿工，来治理国家？他将在2月28日得到答案。汤姆，那并不是他所期待的答案。所以我们明天会回来讲那场选举，1974年的第一次选举，英国被要求选择谁来治理国家。我们明天就会知道结果。但是汤姆，当然，如果人们是我们自己这个小工会的成员，也就是“历史余韵俱乐部”的成员，那么他们将能够听到这个系列的全部内容。嗯，他们可以加入我们一起喝啤酒吃三明治，不是吗？他们确实可以。
That's exactly what they'll be doing. So join us on your space hoppers, please, if you're a member of the Rest is History Club. And if not, you will have to wait. We don't run a three-day week at the Rest is History, not this week. It's a four-episode week. Very exciting.
他们确实会那样做。所以，如果你是“历史余韵俱乐部”的成员，请骑着你的太空跳跳球加入我们。如果不是，你就得等一等。我们“历史余韵”可不实行每周三天工作制，至少这周不是。这周有四集节目。非常令人兴奋。
So we'll see you next time. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
那么我们下次见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余韵》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想收听无广告内容、获得额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。